Anh chá sắp định việc thực hiện hỏi thông sây dựng không một vạc sây dựng không hay,
tu dự án thình phần 2 có nhiều vi pháp.
Măng có lý dự án chấp hận thay đồ một số vực tương vật liệu khác,
một gấp, hoặc không viên, một gấp số sự sò hiệu đồng.
Thì chưa có kết quả thẩm định giá.
Hôm dân nghiệm thu một số máy thiết bị chưa để đủ một số đã hết hạn đăng kìm kìm định.
Đà biệt tổng công ty, bác sống, tên, bác sống,
tên, sẽ pê chuyển vận, chứ nhà thầu khác, một phần công việc.
Thường gọi thông sây dựng không hay chỉ giá bệnh lắm tị đồng.
Hí chưa được chủ đầu tư chấp hận làm nhà thầu vụ.
Mọi gia, tầm công ty bác sống và nhiều tất câu là thành viên liên xanh,
còn kỹ hợp đồng với một số nhà thầu khác.
Tự kiện một phần công việc của có thông sây dựng không hay,
bởi tầm giá chỉ chính trị tị đồng.
Thánh chá sát định đây là anh vi chuyển dựng thông vi pháp lộn thông,
năm nay, nhưng không trong mề ba.
Thánh chá còn sư định, các nhà thầu chính, gồm,
điều trị con, vì con, hành khó, vinh nha con này, công ty cầu phần kết cầu thép à tê đe.
Và phục hơn chuyển nhận, chứ nhà thầu khác một phần công việc.
Thôi hỏi thầu, năm, trấm mời với tầm giá chỉ một liên năng chăm chỉ biết sống tị đồng.
Hí chưa được chủ đầu tư chấp hận làm nhà thầu vụ.
Theo thánh chá chính vụ, các xác phạm sảy ra rồi chủ đầu tư ở vấn đơn vị từ vấn.
Chứ tôn thuộc đầy đủ chính tự tụ tục và các thả thuận trong hợp đồng ở một số lửa dông.
Quá chính làp thầm định phép dự dự tuán lợi cho nhà thầu khoảng liệu rất trết lượng,
hợp đồng và tạm ứng còn nhiều điều sống.
Khá kênh loạn chính nhận thổng về hội đồng thành viên VTM,
hội đồng quan trì ATV, tổng giám đốc và các phó tổng giám đốc theo những vụ được phân công.
Bán khoảng li rằng áng tổ chương ra, các phòng bàn và tổ chức cã nhận thổng về TM, ATV,
chực kép lên quan, cơn vị tương vấn thiết kể từ vấn sám sát và nhà thổ thiết công.
Sau khi chỉ ra các vị phạm thành tra chính vụ đã chuyển thông tiền để mục cơm ăn,
để xem sét điều chá sử li cho quy định đối với một số nhà thầu, chuyển nhận thổ và chủ đấu tư ATV,
đi vọng quy định của lột lỗ thầu, viết phạm quy định về đồng tiền dự thầu, đồng tiền thân trón.